on the flip side of that if
if we're accepting
cheating and our children are also
seeing
the aftermath of that
what
it's it's very small well the kids
shouldn't know i mean i i'm sorry but
yeah that's just the responsibility
that's irresponsible to let your kids
know what your marriage problems are
kids kids know a lot and they don't say
so you might you might not necessarily
want your kids to know or even know that
your children know but
you know they're they're not how how
would kids know that he cheated not
necessarily that he cheated but say for
instance
they might know there's fighting
say for instance i was with i was with
my partner and
he cheated and and that
affected me in a way where i was
completely depressed for a whole year
that's going to affect the children
right but you're depressed yeah but
that's that's yeah but if i'm depressed
i can't look after my children properly
that's a choice that's your that's yours
you're depressed well it's not it's not
it's not about someone because it's
effective okay okay but but you
shouldn't let it affect your kids
wait hold on hold on hold on you said
what so if counseling is guys
you
is a mental health issue yeah you can't
say oh you shouldn't be depressed that
doesn't make sense i'm saying you can be
sad and you you can be depressed but the
way you act is a choice and you should
be a mother first and put you before and
put your kids before you it's not about
you anymore once you have children but
you could try to put them first but
ultimately sometimes for some people you
can get yeah you can you could get help
but i'm saying that help could take a
whole year that that rebuilding of
yourself could take a whole year or six
months
what's the alternative right because the
alternative is putting your kid at a
statistical disadvantage there's a
there's a single mother-to-prison
pipeline so if i put my i put the i put
my kid at the disadvantage not the man
that cheated now if yeah where does the
responsibility
why
because it's whoever it's whoever it's
who breaks up the home
who leaves
whoever
oh wait a minute yeah hold on yeah but
we also said that in cases of domestic
violence it's different like yeah so
what i'm saying is so
i'm with i've i've told to my partner
that i'm gonna have kids with if you
cheat i'm leaving he's decided to cheat
on me and i have left now i've made my
kids become a statistic that's what
you're saying
only if you act a certain way only if
you act a certain way my fault wait let
me explain it okay okay okay i think i
think we can agree common sense right
yeah if you break up your home then you
leave your kids at a statistical
disadvantage yeah whether it's your
fault
when you get married are there not
so vows if a man then then goes out and
cheats then it's isn't it him that
breaks he's broken no because he's
breaking the contract he didn't leave he
didn't leave the marriage but he also
didn't recycle lovers
at a time
you broke
ultimately
you are the catalan you're the catalyst
right right but you're putting yourself
before your children as the mother you
are not so you're supposed to love your
kids more than yourself so detail
himself before all of us can i quickly
ask a question sorry right this now this
is aside from
cheating
if a man was struggling financially
wasn't doing too well with money
he couldn't find a job
he was down in the dumps and his ability
to provide had now been knocked
if he was to to basically just sit
around and mope and act all depressed
what would you say to him
i'm gonna help you get up and get back
on your feet and get back maybe in the
beginning but as time goes because a
minute ago your example was for a year
if i'm depressed does he have a year to
be depressed and not get [ __ ] done you
would now turn around and look at him
and go bollocks to that your feelings
come second to us and the kids and what
goes on in the household and the
security
i think i think that is a massive double
standard i think that that example is a
bit different yeah i would like because
the guy loses his job outside of outside
of history but i did state from the
beginning that he is aside from the
thing but
ultimately where it's the same principle
it's one minute i'm depressed and i'm
putting that on my kids and they're
suffering and if a man is depressed and
he's putting out on the kids and now the
wife and the kids are suffering her
her attitude is you need to man up and
get on with it so why is a woman can you
not put it aside and just get on with it
why do the kids have to suffer
for me personally it's easy for you to
say that but if if i was in a position
where my partner cheated on me however
that affects me it can affect me forever
long i can't i would i would hate for
somebody to say put that aside for the
because of the kids in the woman's sake
i would argue i would absolutely argue
it's because they are far more emotional
either way either it's natural it's it's
easy for you to do something to hurt
somebody and say i'll get over it for
because of the kids i feel like that i
understand where you're coming from but
if you're the one causing that pain you
can't then be the same one saying get
over it but you but you but you can mask
it to the point where the kids don't
need to suffer in both cases
that's what i'm saying i'm saying it's
about the kids yeah it's not about your
personal feelings it's about your
children yeah so
can i just clarify that
so we've got married
you know if you cheat that i can't
cannot stay with you because it will
kill me inside it'll make me
whatever oh my god terrible
so you cheat we have kids you cheat
it it is selfish to cheat no no i know
what you're saying so
he's cheated i i haven't done anything
i'm at home playing with my kid with our
kids okay i've done something
shut up if i leave
it's my fault okay who's whose feelings
are more important the kids are you
everyone's no whose feelings are more
important because me and the kids that's
whose feelings are more important the
kids are you
it has to be the kids okay okay so say i
let it go once then for the kids what
happens if you choose again
i'm not holding on for nothing i've got
the car keys i'm out of there hold on
sorry all right so every month yeah a
woman has a period yeah yeah as men
we deal with this
oh oh please i have not even wait let me
laugh bro i'm sitting in the air like
what my man said let me laugh
hold on
you see this this this is what this this
is so hard for a man to explain because
all right do you go through periods
every month yeah do you chemically
change every month yes are you
emotionally unstable every month
yes
no no all situations
i've been around to be honest oh come on
no no to be honest but we have to be
honest we can't just we can't generally
speak into the mic we can't generalize
i've had many girlfriends many links
many whoever just as you have but in my
personal experience they've never
treated me differently or acted
differently to a point where i can say
you're emotionally
unbalanced because you're on your period
to me i'm not saying it doesn't happen
i'm not saying it doesn't happen but in
my experience
why are you shaking your hands
he said not in general but we're dealing
with generals hold on hold on
it's what you gotta say i'm
on the cheating topic right i'm saying
we just need to be honest right if i'm
in a marriage and my wife takes a penis
in her vagina and i leave
i can't be the one to blame for breaking
the would you take would you carry the
blame if your wife cheated and you and
you divorced just yes do you want me to
answer the question before i've even
landed on my main point oh sorry i mean
i don't know
you don't have a period so you wouldn't
know if a woman has an emotional i mean
um would you call it a a different
chemical experience from a period yeah
which they release a hormone yeah which
makes them chemically different
that okay you don't that doesn't change
that that's facts yeah i'm not
challenges all right so i'm saying
that yeah so i'm saying as a man
when a woman goes through that certain
time of the month yeah we are
conditioned to kind of
adjust navigate
her feelings yeah
so a woman in her brain
does understand that a certain time
a chemical changes in her head where she
does not act normal
but yet she can't understand the same
chemical not the same chemical but the
same
chemical reaction happens in a man where
he can't control but you can
control
you can control because when you're at
work and your period pain you could be
very nice to your boss but as soon as
you come home to your husband it's like
ah it's like no no you know you don't
have to control it wait wait wait what
i'm saying
where are you getting that from yeah i
don't know where you're getting that
information
which part of the information
i'm on one everywhere like no no one is
is like everyone so you're trying to
tell me if you wanna if you're on your
period and you're feeling very irritable
you're gonna take it out on your manager
100
come on man is that is that
is okay okay you don't know how to
control your emotions at work
i i don't have to if i if i if i don't
want to i won't
i don't know man
i feel like it's incomparable i feel
like
i feel like the concept the concept of a
person feeling hurt because you've
broken the marital vows and in
comparison to
and and and
her being put in a condition where we're
telling her to deal with it in
comparison to a man dealing with his
partner on her period is very they're
very difficult
you answer the question please about um
if
so the marriage is there
we're all happy families and i've went
out yeah and i've cheated yeah
so you're gonna stay with me no that's
right
hold on hold on
the feelings of the kids first don't you
as a man one at a time guys that's a
call guys
what so all i'm trying to say is on a
human level right everybody would be
hurt if i'm in a marriage my wife
doesn't doesn't have to have sex if she
kisses a guy she sucks his dick and i
know and i leave do you think i'm going
to accept from society that i'm the one
who brought
anyone who says that
be realistic really i think i think in
all situations that it would be on the
woman like they would say
she broke if she broke up the family no
forget i'm saying you if you leave
okay first of all if your wife sucks
another man's dick
what are you doing staying or leaving
you but
no no no no
no no no
i'm leaving
guys guys it has to be one at a time
we've got away from something as a man
you can leave and the kids can still not
suffer because if the woman has cheated
and the man leaves how she conducts
herself and how the man conducts himself
around the kids will be what dictates
whether the kids suffer or not it's not
about whether you leave or how she
treats the kids afterwards or how she is
around the kids whether she's her i
agree as many of you know i was just
banned on tic tac and we are demonetized
on a daily basis on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible